your player Austin Reeves playing in his
first postseason he grew up on a farm in
Newark Arkansas his mother and father
both played at Arkansas State Austin won
three state titles in high school and
started his college career at Wichita
State before transferring to Oklahoma
after signing with the Lakers as an
undrafted free agent in 2021 Reese was
fourth on the team in scoring this
season he has said that every time he
stepped on the court in these playoffs
he cannot help but reflect on how far
he's come in his career he said this is
special for me to be here Mike well at
least you think about it he goes from a
small town in Arkansas to the bright
Spotlight of the Lakers here in the
conference final
and as you mentioned it's his first
playoff his first playoff game was on
the road in Memphis he had 23 points he
scored 20 or more five times the new 13
games including 23 the other night in
game one here with eight assists no
turnovers in 42 minutes
he's Fearless talked about he's going to
make a lot of money in free agency what
I love about his thought is he's
aggressive not just as a shooter for
putting the ball on the deck